hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan this is my
first post of the year for Telus talks
business and we're starting a new series
it's called the challenge series we're
going to be answering the questions of
entrepreneurs and giving you some ideas
to help you grow a business so in our
first post today it question comes in
from Jennifer ripple who has a company
at West called white aqua Coulee which
creates eco-friendly tableware for kids
and her question is what is the most
productive form of advertising for a
small business to answer this question
I'd first look at where most of your
customers coming from right now
especially in the early days of a
business it's important to ask each of
your clients how they found out about
you once you know more about how they
found you is worth looking into
advertising to see if there's a way you
can market yourself so more people come
to you you want to be where your
potential customers are otherwise you're
wasting your time and your money for
example let's think and a lot of young
moms buying from and they're telling
each other about your products can you
improve sales by joining young moms
groups partnering with other businesses
that market to them sponsor an event or
newsletter for them join their Facebook
pages and get involved engage with
community leaders and bloggers and so on
there's no one best way for every
business you have to find what works for
you that being said the most cost
effective way for most entrepreneurs is
to go online the cost less you get
real-time data and you can change your
messaging on the fly here are three
suggestions for you number one Google
AdWords with Google AdWords you pick
keywords you think will drive sales and
your advertisement will show up when
people search for those words you can
use a Google Keyword tool which is free
to help you determine what kind of
volume each keyword generates and how
much you can expect to pay to advertise
for example a search for eco-friendly
tableware produces this result the
competition is medium globally it
searched 590 times per month in Canada
it searched 36 times per month and you
can expect to pay a dollar and 20 cents
each time someone clicks on your ad
from here you can expand your search to
find more keywords with a higher volume
and less competition as with all your
marketing you must test to see what's
working
Google AdWords will also give you a
tracking code which you can put on your
website to measure conversions since you
can handle ecommerce you'll be able to
see not just how much revenue AdWords
generates but specifically which
keywords generate the most revenue once
you know the keywords that are
performing well you can optimize your
campaign to bring on new related
keywords as well as potentially increase
your budget for the selected keywords
since you know they're working
number two Facebook advertising I always
do first search the social media when
you're trying to sell a product or
service when someone is searching for
eco-friendly tableware or something
similar they're looking for a solution
to a problem they're having that you can
help them solve their pain they'll buy
from you on social media sites people
have a much greater tendency to browse
instead of buy they weren't looking for
eco-friendly tableware but they're on
Facebook chatting and catching up with
their friends and they saw your ad so
they click through because the pain
isn't there it's a conversion rates go
down but you can still make it work
Facebook is my favorite social media
advertising platform because you can set
specific criteria over who will see your
ad your first step here is to create a
profile of your target ideal customer
for example it could be women between
the ages of 25 and 45 and also live in
Canada or within 100 miles of your
location you can then pick specific
interests that they might have for
example you can target people who like
children's books or even people who
follow brands like a pro crombie kids
you can get as detailed as you want and
only those people will see your ad the
pain isn't as strong with those specific
targeting is much better so if you have
an ideal customer profile in mind it's
worth testing out Facebook advertising
you set a budget limit and Facebook will
also give you recommended pricing
depending on your campaign finally you
can also run split tests so you can have
multiple odds competing against each
other and you can stick with the one who
performs the best as with any
advertising start small and measure to
see if it converts the sales before
spending a lot of money on it
it's easy to ramp up if you know it's
profitable for you
number three search engine optimization
or SEO this is an officially form of
advertising but a cost resources and
competes with the money you have
available to spend on ad campaigns SEO
is one of the most effective ways that
drive new business for entrepreneurs
it's like Google AdWords but only more
effective think about your own browsing
experience when use Google are you more
likely to click on the links or the ads
Edwards is great because it gives you an
immediate inflow of traffic you push the
button and prospects are landing on your
website SEO takes a lot more time my
favorite models to combine them start
with AdWords you get instant traffic and
more importantly you get data on which
keywords are working or not
make sure you set up your tracking once
you know which keywords generate sales
you can then create an SEO campaign
around them because SEO takes time and
resources you want to make sure that the
keywords you pick are going to deliver
for you
planning the campaign around
underperforming keywords is just a waste
of time and money and you can't really
tell which ones are will work until you
test if the keywords are working AdWords
then they'll work for you with SEO once
your SEO efforts take off it doesn't
mean you have to catch your AdWords
campaign again testing and measuring
will tell you what is working as long as
each method is working for you keep
using it it was working very well look
at ways to expand it and if it's not
working well cancel I have lots of small
starts and build up the ones that
generate conversions
thank you for joining me for another
edition of ask Evan if you liked the
video you want to see more please give
it a thumbs up below I'd also love to
hear all you have to think if you want
to leave a comment under the video and
if you'd like to be featured in one of
our challenge videos and get your
questions answered feel free to leave it
in the comments below and we'll consider
you for the next video so thank you and
we'll see you soon
Oh